[Music]
russians
it's fun to judge people i'm i'm married
to i'm married to a russian
and eastern european scared that's what
you would think
see that's how i felt about it for like
four years okay and
russians are they're a weird group of
individuals they're very intense
and women are super mean compared to
canadians okay like eastern european
women
are mean people but if you actually make
friends with them then you have this
kind of bond where they'll do
anything for you like they'll have
bodies yeah yeah yep and they'll just be
like no problem
don't even don't even mention it we'll
never talk about it again body's gone
it's hidden
figured out because they have other
russian connections let us have some
vodka yeah yeah
yep yeah and you don't get that like i
haven't you don't get that as much i'm
sure you can find it in
north american culture but it's not it's
like oh well we were friends for 10
years but like
i've got a thing and yeah i did talk to
this other person about you
and like sorry yeah they're just like
ride or dies
russians yeah it's weird it's like they
hate you and they're mean and
evil and untrustworthy and then you get
in and and it's just like this wonderful
group of individuals
that kind of sounds awesome it is
awesome see i have european eastern
european
in me yeah like the the russian
ukrainian polish
oh yeah i have polish i've pulled you
crying in and then apparently
some of them went out that way but yeah
i see those women and i'm like ah we all
look the same all right yeah yeah
when i went to sweden everyone there
spoke swedish to me because they all
thought i was swedish
so i just had to start learning basic
and then oh my god have you been to
switzerland
yeah love it i went to zurich and i've
never seen more attractive people than
the people who live in zurich
i thought sweden was more attractive the
guys were all in
tights like yoga pants and you could see
everything all day every day
and like long t-shirts but like with
tights
yeah with tights and they were so hot
and i was just like what are these
humans
all of you need to just procreate all
day like this is
like the world health organization
should force them to procreate just to
make the world better looking
you know i'm not trying to like hitler
it up in like aryan race but like those
are good looking humans
i see i felt like that kind of in
switzerland
people they were unbelievably attractive
yeah what'd you do about it i'm just
kidding i just like
i i just like stared at people awkwardly
oh yeah
i was walking around i don't know what
happened it was like a rough period of
time and i was walking around one of my
shoes was broken i
had flip-flops what happens to you when
you stream like
i didn't say street walk that time okay
walking around walking around
but you know when your flip-flop breaks
and then it doesn't work at all anymore
so i was walking around with one
shoe in zurich which is full of like
anyone who can afford to live in zurich
okay um
yeah and i went to a store just to buy
these like shitty little flip-flops and
people there were
i was just staring at people wow yeah i
know i was like wow look at your face
it's just like you could like you could
move to north america and then just
make money on instagram you don't have
to be selling flip-flops
yeah maybe we should they don't know
that though them
we should bring that could we should
take a cut agency of course come on it's
business oh my god that's
actually a really good idea